the popular retailer build-a-bear is
trying to make amends after it pulled
the plug on a big sale due to
overwhelming demand thousands of people
lined up at stores across the country
and in Canada and the UK for deep
discounts yesterday but the massive
crowds triggered safety concerns and
people were turned away Manuel Bojorquez
shows us how that left some customers in
tears
Manuel good morning good morning it was
billed as the first ever pay your age
day so a five-year-old child would pay
five dollars for a stuffed animal like
this one which can usually retail for
around $30 for a few thousand families
it was a deal too good to pass up
leading to a day of retail chaos long
lines were forming before the
build-a-bear stores open Thursday
morning we want to build a bear but by
midday on the East Coast the crowds had
become too much forcing build-a-bear to
issue an alert on Twitter for local
authorities we cannot accept additional
guests at our locations due to crowd
safety concerns however the event which
had been advertised to members of the
chains Rewards program had already drawn
crowds all around the country in Arizona
Washington Florida New York it's been a
little tough wanting to move and the
lines not moving very fast
so it's been a struggle that's insanity
I mean bring your kids out at 100
degrees I'm in for stupid stuff bear
eventually build-a-bear decided to shut
down the sale claiming they had not
anticipated this kind of a response
disappointed customers were offered $15
vouchers a move that did little to
satisfy some angry parents who took to
social media my son broke down in tears
when the security officer yelled in my
face to go get a voucher like everyone
else we waited for three hours before
giving up my daughter cried all the way
home but when we visited this Glendale
California kiosk the line was still
moving and this determined 13 year old
went home with the furry friend she came
for tell me about how long you waited in
line that 13-year old told me this was
her first time getting one because
typically a visit to the store would
just be too expensive the company is
encouraging anyone who picked up a
voucher to delay their return visit to
the store to avoid a repeat of the
crowds Gianna Manuel thank you I guess
the takeaway is don't promise what you
can't deliver right also in a day and
age of iPhones and fancy video games the
good old-fashioned teddy bear still gets
people out not the PR they wanted this
yeah that is also true